It's hard to believe it's been more than 25
years since the release of Steven Spielberg's
Hook, the fantasy adventure about a middle-aged
Peter Pan returning to Neverland.
Two of the famous grown-ups in the cast are
no longer with us: Hollywood legend Robin
Williams as Peter and British screen and stage
star Bob Hoskins, as Mr. Smee.
Others, including Julia Roberts as Tinkerbell,
Dustin Hoffman as Captain Hook, and Maggie
Smith as Wendy, are still working steadily
in the spotlight today.
But what about the lesser-known members of
the cast?
What do they look like today?
Think happy thoughts, because were about to
find out.
Charles Korsmo - Jack Banning
Korsmo played Peter's son Jack, who gets abducted
by Captain Hook.
The dastardly pirate plays on Jack's anger
with his workaholic father and attempts to
bond with the boy to thwart his nemesis.
Following Hook, Korsmo appeared in only one
more film: 1998's Can't Hardly Wait.
As of the making of this video, Korsmo is
slated to appear in an upcoming 2018 film
called Chained For Life, but has a different
day job than acting.
These days, Korsmo is a lawyer and associate
law professor at Case Western Reserve University.
Amber Scott - Maggie Banning
Scott played the adorably precocious daughter
of Peter Pan, Maggie Banning.
Kidnapped along with her brother Jack, she
famously called her captor out for his bad
behavior …
"You need a mother very, very badly!"
She also sang a song in the movie, "When You're
Alone," which was nominated for an Oscar.
Like her onscreen "brother" Charles Korsmo,
Scott chose not to pursue an acting career
following Hook.
She's had only one other role to-date: a voice-acting
credit for a documentary in 1995.
Caroline Goodall - Moira Banning
Goodall played Moira, granddaughter to Wendy
and wife of Peter.
Moira and Peter argue about his work conflicting
with his role as a father; later, the couple
discovers that their two children have been
abducted by Captain Hook.
Goodall later landed numerous high profile
roles in television and film, including Schindler's
List opposite Liam Neeson, and The Princess
Diaries with Anne Hathaway.
Isaiah Robinson - Pockets
Robinson played one of the many oddly-named
Lost Boys who Peter encounters in Neverland.
In one famous scene, the Lost Boys don't initially
believe that the middle-aged man before them
is actually Peter Pan.
Pockets reaches out to touch his face, finally
recognizing him …
"Oh, there you are, Peter!"
Following Hook, Robinson booked only one additional
acting credit, for a role in the 2005 film
Dead at the Box Office.
He now works as a singer for the Los Angeles
Opera.
Jasen Fisher - Ace
You may remember Fisher as the Lost Boy who
wore a raggedy top hat and helped his comrades
whip Peter back into shape.
Fisher also starred in two other films as
a child, Parenthood and The Witches, although
his role as "Ace" in Hook marked his last
acting credit.
Fisher reunited with his Parenthood castmates
not long ago and shared that he currently
lives in Florida and works as a professional
golf caddy.
Dante Basco - Rufio
Everyone remembers the Lost Boy with a bad
attitude who assumed leadership over the group
after Peter Pan went away.
When Peter returns to Neverland, Dante Basco's
Rufio isn't willing to give up his authority
at first, but after Peter finally proves he's
regained his memories, Rufio willingly gives
up his sword.
Basco is also known for his tear-jerking death
scene ..
"I wish I had a dad like you."
Since Hook, Basco has continued to act, focusing
on voice work for several animated series
and video games.
Raushan Hammond - Thud Butt
Hammond played the jolly Lost Boy who rolls
down some stairs and bowls over several pirates
during the battle with Captain Hook.
After Peter decides to return to the real
world, he leaves Thud Butt in charge of the
group.
"I want you to take care of everyone who's
smaller than you."
"Okay."
Following Hook, he picked up a few more roles
in the 1990s; in 2011, he acted in and directed
the low-budget heist flick 24 Hours in Las
Vegas.
James Madio - Don't Ask
The Lost Boy with a smart mouth, a tweed jacket,
and a feather earring dangling from one ear
was known as "Don't Ask."
Hook marked James Madio's first acting role,
but he never looked back after that: he's
continued to act, appearing in dozens of films
and television series since.
You may also remember Madio for his role in
HBO's Band of Brothers.
Madio also appeared in an episode of the police
drama Blue Bloods, and he's slated to star
in the boxing biopic Pep.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!